Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 37, Funky Languages. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So, yeah, we got an interesting question from many interesting questions yeah we got several interesting yeah definitely several interesting
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 37 期，Funky Languages。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。是的，我们收到了很多有趣的问题，确实收到了好几个有趣的问题。
questions um i try to answer them on uh you know google plus slash facebook slash twitter wherever they come slash email but uh this one was particularly interesting, so we wanted to discuss it on the show. So Will wrote in and said, basically, what do you guys think about moving to Silicon Valley? I live on the East Coast. He lives in a small town in Georgia. I'm assuming he's doing tech, developing mobile applications. And he just wants to know, should uh you know make the trip over to silicon valley so i don't know what do you think i'll i'll uh i'll let you have the first shot of this there are many factors which should influence one's decision to relocate oh god first
嗯，我试着在 Google Plus、Facebook、Twitter 或任何他们联系我的地方，或者通过电子邮件回答这些问题。但这个问题特别有趣，所以我们想在节目中讨论一下。Will 写信问，基本上，你们觉得搬到硅谷怎么样？我住在东海岸。他住在佐治亚州的一个小镇。我假设他从事科技行业，开发移动应用程序。他只是想知道，他是否应该去硅谷。我不知道你们怎么看，我先让你们来回答这个问题。有很多因素会影响一个人搬迁的决定。天哪，首先……
uh so no no but seriously like um if you've never visited and you haven't like if you're just thinking like should i interview the answer is yes you should probably interview well that makes sense more generally you should interview uh part of that is you'll probably get a chance to come out here because we are in the silicon valley so that's why i say here right so you get a chance to come out and visit see what it's like but i mean everybody will tell you that property is really expensive expensive to buy a place to live in or even just to rent a place at least in the really uh kind of main part of silicon valley but there is a reason why everybody wants to live here that is that there's a lot of good places to work and you know the area is beautiful the
好吧，不，说真的，如果你从来没去过，如果你只是在想“我应该去面试吗”，答案是肯定的，你可能应该去面试。这很有道理，更广泛地说，你应该去面试。部分原因是，你很可能会有机会来到这里，因为我们就在硅谷，所以我才说“这里”。所以你有机会过来看看这里是什么样子的。但我的意思是，每个人都会告诉你，这里的房产真的很贵，买房或租房都很贵，至少在硅谷的核心地带是这样。但每个人都想住在这里是有原因的，那就是这里有很多好工作，而且这个地区很美，
weather is great um and people love paying taxes. People love paying taxes. I think you make a really good point. If you interview, provided you make it past the phone screen, you basically get a free trip to Silicon Valley. That's for most big companies. Every company is a little different, but most big companies are that way. Even startups, actually. is a little different but most big companies are that way even startups actually like uh when i was looking around when i was still on the east coast um uh startups would also pay for you to for you
天气很好，而且人们喜欢交税。人们喜欢交税。我觉得你说的很有道理。如果你去面试，只要通过了电话筛选，你基本上就获得了一次免费的硅谷之旅。大多数大公司都是这样。每家公司都有所不同，但大多数大公司都是这样。其实连初创公司也是。就像我还在东海岸的时候，初创公司也会为你支付……
to come okay yeah at the time i was interviewing at tesla and uh at the time they were like really small company and they they uh they totally flew me over there or offered to fly me over there ended up picking a different company. But, but yeah, so, so, you know, you can interview, get a free trip,
过来面试的费用。好吧，当时我在特斯拉面试，那时他们还是一家非常小的公司，他们完全愿意飞我过去，或者提出飞我过去。最后我选择了另一家公司。但是，是的，所以你可以去面试，获得一次免费的旅行。
make sure you, if possible interview on, you know, like a Monday or Friday. So you can come the weekend or at least, that's true, you know, take some days off or something.
如果可能的话，确保在周一或周五面试。这样你就可以在周末过来，或者至少，那是真的，你知道，请几天假之类的。
And be upfront with the recruiter, right? Because their job is to be very nice to you. And I was, I'm always, I give this advice, but I know I was always very timid and asking for things or accommodation basically but you know if you have a significant other a spouse or something don't take advantage of it in my opinion but like you know if they're debating whether or not they would also like to move you should say
而且要对招聘人员坦诚，对吧？因为他们的工作就是对你非常友好。我总是给出这个建议，但我知道我以前总是很胆小，不敢要求什么，或者不敢要求基本的住宿。但如果你有另一半、配偶之类的，在我看来，不要占便宜，但如果你在纠结他们是否也想搬过来，你应该说……
hey like as a as a couple we're determining this like is it possible for my wife to join me on this trip or whatever yeah that's that's a really good point i mean i i didn't do that and i kind of regretted it i mean it it worked out fine but uh it was a little nerve-wracking for my wife to uh like literally her first day in california was the day we moved and it's like, there's really no going back. And so, yeah,
嘿，作为一对伴侣，我们正在考虑这个问题，我妻子能和我一起参加这次旅行吗？之类的。是的，这确实是一个很好的观点。我的意思是，我当时没这么做，我有点后悔。虽然最后结果还不错，但对我妻子来说有点紧张，因为她到加州的第一天就是我们搬家的那天，真的没有回头路了。所以，是的，
if I had to do it over again, I would have asked, you know, if you think about it, if you interview at like a big company, you know, uh, you know,
如果让我重来一次，我会问的。你知道，如果你仔细想想，如果你去一家大公司面试，你知道，
two or $300 plane ticket. I mean, they, you know, they're not gonna, it's not gonna set them back and it could really do. And having another person isn't really that big a deal because like, you know, they don't have to pay for another hotel room or really anything um so there i did ask it
两三百美元的机票。我的意思是，他们不会因为这个而损失什么，而且这真的很有帮助。带上另一个人其实也没什么大不了的，因为他们不需要支付额外的酒店房间费用，或者其他任何费用。所以我确实问过，
from one recruiter um not for the bay area but um for another area and i did ask and they said that i could i didn't end up taking them up on it because i ended up taking another offer um but i they were very you know sure of course you know like that's no problem and i had actually already flown there and interviewed and i was asking to fly me and my wife together out again to do kind of like an exploration trip and they were okay with that as well yeah right so um that totally makes sense so getting back to the question oh yeah um yeah no no i mean so you're right that you should definitely interview and all that so we didn't waste time or anything okay but but the uh should you move Silicon Valley so um here's my take on it so it's a little bit of a different question but it'll come back to the main point somebody asked me how come we can't just recreate Silicon Valley you know in Florida
问过一位招聘人员，不是针对湾区，而是针对另一个地区。我问了，他们说可以。我最后没有接受，因为我接受了另一份工作。但他们非常肯定，当然没问题。我当时其实已经飞过去面试过了，我是在要求他们再次飞我和我妻子过去，进行一次探索之旅，他们也同意了。是的，没错。所以，回到问题上来。哦，是的，没错，你是对的，你绝对应该去面试，所有这些。所以我们没有浪费时间。好的，但是关于“你应该搬到硅谷吗”，这是我的看法。这是一个稍微不同的问题，但会回到重点。有人问我，为什么我们不能在佛罗里达……
or or somewhere else right and there's been many attempts. There's a place in India that's supposed to be like a technology triangle that's trying to be like an incubator. There's a lot of places all over the world that are like kind of tech incubators. And a lot of them get traction. And of course, they're successful to some degree, but none of them are close to the success of Silicon Valley. Right. And what I think about this is that you have sort of this pool of talent and a lot of the information you need to be a successful tech company is sort of latent. you know it's it's lessons learned it's not something you can really find in school especially now because you know there's so much disconnect like people in silicon valley aren't going back to university and teaching or anything like that so there's just so many lessons to be learned and so much um sort of what's the word for it where it's like uh you just kind of have to you know be grandfathered into it there's
或其他地方重建硅谷？已经有很多尝试了。印度有一个地方号称是技术三角区，试图成为孵化器。世界各地有很多地方都像是科技孵化器。其中很多也取得了一些进展。当然，它们在某种程度上是成功的，但没有一个能接近硅谷的成功。没错。我认为这是因为你拥有某种人才库，而且成为一家成功的科技公司所需的信息在某种程度上是潜在的。你知道，这是经验教训，不是你在学校里真正能学到的东西，尤其是现在，因为硅谷的人并没有回到大学去教书之类的。所以有太多的经验教训需要学习，而且有太多的……怎么说呢，就像你必须被“祖父化”进入这个圈子，
not really a way to learn other than yeah it's like this this language that's evolved over time that basically you know to be a successful company you need a couple of say you know silicon valley veterans and so if there was some kind of migration out of the valley then we could get these incubators and other places but at the moment you know the best place and one of the valley then we could get these incubators and other places but at the moment you know the best place and one of the only places to get sort of veterans who have been doing you know big data or or you know practical machine learning or whatever um is is here and those people aren't moving so um so there are other but there are other places like i i read stuff a lot um about new york right it's not to the same degree of startups but like new york city has a lot of
除了这种方式，真的没有其他学习方法。这就像一种随着时间演变的语言，基本上，要成为一家成功的公司，你需要几个硅谷老手。所以，如果硅谷出现某种人才外流，我们就能在其他地方建立这些孵化器。但目前，获得那些做过大数据、实用机器学习等方面的老手的最佳地点，也是唯一地点，就是这里。而这些人并没有搬走。所以，还有其他地方，比如我经常读到关于纽约的内容，虽然初创公司的程度不如硅谷，但纽约市确实有很多……
tech jobs and and yeah that's true and it somewhat i think is partly just the you need a certain density of people and then a certain percentage of those people to be you know technologically minded advanced computer science people like that kind of stuff and the areas like if you take uh you know jason and i are both from florida if you take the areas in florida where we were even if there may be a lot of people the density is relatively low and uh the number of people who are from a technology background is also very low right and there's a chicken and an egg problem because let's say you're a brand new company. Like you're some startup, you just have an idea.
科技工作。是的，那是真的。我认为这在一定程度上是因为你需要一定的人口密度，然后其中一定比例的人必须是具有技术头脑、高级计算机科学背景的人。如果你看看佛罗里达，Jason 和我都是佛罗里达人，如果你看看我们所在的地区，即使那里可能有很多人口，但密度相对较低，而且有技术背景的人数也非常少。这是一个“先有鸡还是先有蛋”的问题，因为假设你是一家全新的公司。比如你是一家初创公司，你只有一个想法。
You know, you're Ubar and you want to be, you know, a phone app where people can request bars that they show up, bartenders and they show up. You know, you're going to have like a little bit of funding to get started and you need to get some very talented people or at least one very talented person to build, you know, version one of the system. That means you're going to have to find someone who's willing to quit their job and take a huge risk to join your company. And that means you have to go through a lot of people like
你是 Uber，你想成为一个手机应用，人们可以请求酒吧，调酒师就会出现。你会有一些启动资金，你需要找到一些非常有才华的人，或者至少一个非常有才华的人来构建系统的第一个版本。这意味着你必须找到一个愿意辞职并承担巨大风险加入你公司的人。这意味着你必须接触很多人，比如……
it might be a one in 10,000 chance that you find someone who's in that position. And so if you go to, say, Florida, where there might only be 9,000 people who have that kind of skill set, now you're really in trouble, right? And so because of that, you don't have this sort of snowball effect and so silicon valley is like one of the few places where you can um where you can go and find some very senior people to work on something you know that's just an idea right yeah so so i would say should i move it's obviously subject to a lot of personal decisions and it is expensive to live here but i mean there are two things that are good is one is jason kind of talked about like those talented people it's also good for you as an employee because there's a lot of people to learn from uh and a lot of really smart people typically um right yeah there are not smart people
你找到处于那种位置的人的几率可能是万分之一。所以如果你去佛罗里达，那里可能只有 9000 人具备那种技能，那你就有大麻烦了。正因为如此，你没有这种滚雪球效应。所以硅谷是少数几个你可以去寻找一些非常资深的人来从事一个仅仅是想法的项目的地方。是的，所以我会说，我应该搬吗？这显然取决于很多个人决定，而且住在这里确实很贵。但有两件事是好的：一是 Jason 提到的那些人才，这对你作为员工也很有好处，因为有很多可以学习的对象，而且通常有很多非常聪明的人。
too i guess but there are a lot of smart people and if you can find them you can learn a lot not even at your own company but just like everywhere right it's all around you yeah definitely the other thing is like, for me, it's much better to move on my terms. Like I decided like I wanted to move and moved out here. And then now if something happened and I was forced into needing to get a different job or there was a downturn in my company, right?
对，也有不聪明的人，我想。但有很多聪明人，如果你能找到他们，你可以学到很多，甚至不需要在自己的公司，到处都是。是的，绝对是。另一件事是，对我来说，按我的条件搬家要好得多。我决定我想搬家，然后搬到了这里。如果现在发生了什么事，我被迫需要找另一份工作，或者我的公司出现了经济衰退，对吧？
Then I would be forced to relocate. And if I'm here, the chance of me having to relocate away is uh low compared to where i was before yeah that's true now there's still the problem of like what happens like what happened in 2000s with the tech burst tech bubble burst um but i'm already in the tech industry so like in general it's going to be a bad time for me regardless of where i am yeah definitely definitely so uh yeah actually it's kind of it's quite interesting when the tech bubble burst i don't know if there was necessarily like uh like people out of a job actually no i take it back yeah i read stories about people like i think
那么我将被迫搬迁。如果我在这里，我被迫搬离这里的几率很低，相比我以前住的地方。是的，那是真的。现在仍然存在像 2000 年代科技泡沫破裂那样的问题，但我已经在科技行业了，所以无论我在哪里，这对我来说通常都是一段糟糕的时期。是的，绝对是。所以，其实当科技泡沫破裂时，这很有趣。我不知道是否一定有很多人失业，其实不，我收回这句话。我读过关于人们的故事，我想……
it got pretty bad yeah yeah that's true but uh to be honest i find it very unlikely i do think that there is a little bit of a bubble now, but I think if it bursts, there's such a lack of talent that the companies that are established will just swoop up all of the talent. I don't feel like that well will run dry.
情况变得很糟糕。是的，那是真的。但老实说，我觉得这不太可能。我确实认为现在有一点泡沫，但如果它破裂了，由于人才如此匮乏，那些成熟的公司会迅速吸纳所有人才。我不觉得那个源泉会枯竭。
So basically, the long answer is it's up to you. I think it's fair to speak for for both of speak for both of us I say that you know we love it here but but yeah you should definitely bring you know your significant other if you have one and and and give it a good evaluation you know before you come so yeah so speaking of Silicon Valley and startups how does a a startup work? Yeah. So, you know, I think, you know, we've been in Silicon Valley, you're completely inundated
所以，长话短说，这取决于你自己。我觉得代表我们俩说，我们都很喜欢这里，这是公平的。但是的，如果你有另一半，你绝对应该带上他们，在来之前好好评估一下。所以，说到硅谷和初创公司，初创公司是如何运作的？是的。你知道，我觉得我们身处硅谷，完全被初创公司淹没了，
with startups, like reading about startups, friends who go to work for startups, things like that. But, you know, I was thinking about this the other day that when I was in Florida, I really had no idea sort of what a startup is or anything. And, you know, we're both tech savvy people, but it's just not a, it's really just a part of Silicon Valley culture. And so I felt like I wanted to try to share that with everyone. So, you know, neither Patrick nor I have ever worked in a startup.
比如阅读关于初创公司的文章，朋友去初创公司工作等等。但是，前几天我在想，当我在佛罗里达时，我真的不知道什么是初创公司。我们都是精通技术的人，但这真的不是硅谷文化的一部分。所以我感觉我想尝试和大家分享这一点。所以，Patrick 和我都没有在初创公司工作过。
We both have friends who are at startups or have started startups. And yeah, basically, so this is kind of how it works in a nutshell. And Patrick, please correct me because I'm sure I'm going to mess stuff up. But you typically try to start by contacting venture capitalists. So you make a very quick prototype. So some common examples are the Zappos, that Zappos shoe sales website. The guy actually started by going to Payless, like a real brick and mortar, like a Payless shoe store, taking pictures of the shoes there and then going on his computer and making
我们都有在初创公司工作或创办过初创公司的朋友。基本上，这就是初创公司的运作方式。Patrick，请纠正我，因为我肯定会搞砸一些事情。但你通常尝试通过联系风险投资家来开始。所以你制作一个非常快速的原型。一些常见的例子是 Zappos，那个 Zappos 鞋类销售网站。那个人最初是去 Payless，一家真正的实体鞋店，拍下那里的鞋子照片，然后在电脑上制作……
an HTML page selling those shoes for I think it was like a 10 or 15% markup online. And then literally, if someone would buy the shoes, he would walk down the street to the Payless, buy the shoes, mail them himself, right? So it's like super, super low tech. But it was enough to go to a venture capitalist and say, look, I've been doing this for a month and I got, you know, 2000 people ordering shoes. And then what will happen is another way to do it is they have these. I don't know if I'd really call them competitions. I guess maybe like incubators. like Stardex and some of these other ones where you sort of enter a competition and you pitch an idea, you know, with varying degrees of completion. And then they choose, you know, some winners and
一个在线销售这些鞋子的 HTML 页面，加价大概 10% 或 15%。如果有人买鞋，他就会走到街上的 Payless，买下鞋子，自己邮寄出去。所以这非常非常低科技。但这足以去见风险投资家说：“看，我这样做了一个月，我有 2000 人订购了鞋子。”然后会发生的是，另一种方法是他们有这些……我不知道是否真的称之为比赛。我想也许是孵化器，比如 Stardex 和其他一些，你参加比赛并推销一个想法，完成度各不相同。然后他们选择一些赢家，
those winners, you know, get connected with venture capitalists. But your goal is to get connected to a VC or a venture capitalist. What they will do is they will give you some money, like maybe $5 million or $10 million. But they don't give it to you. They give it to the company. And then as part of giving the company this money, they also sort of set up the company and they set up all the infrastructure you need to run a company. So you and the venture capitalists
那些赢家会与风险投资家建立联系。但你的目标是联系到 VC 或风险投资家。他们会给你一些钱，比如 500 万或 1000 万美元。但他们不是直接给你，而是给公司。作为提供这笔钱的一部分，他们也会建立公司，并设置运行公司所需的所有基础设施。所以你和风险投资家……
together figure out for example how much you should get paid so like however much you should get paid that's money that isn't going into the company and so you know also like how much of the company you own like if you want a really big salary then the venture capitalist is going to say okay but now you're only going to own 10% of your company instead of owning like, you know, 50% of your company. So it's sort of like how much do you want to risk and things like that. Once you've sort of set all that up, then now you have this money. You can use the money and your prototype to try to get, you know, some of your friends or other people in the valley to join your company and and you can pay them and it's the same deal for them like you can give them money and you can give them
一起决定，例如你应该拿多少薪水。你拿的薪水越多，投入公司的钱就越少。还有你拥有公司多少股份，如果你想要很高的薪水，风险投资家会说“好吧，但现在你只能拥有公司 10% 的股份，而不是 50%”。所以这取决于你想要承担多少风险。一旦你设置好了一切，你现在就有钱了。你可以利用这笔钱和你的原型，尝试让你的朋友或其他硅谷的人加入你的公司，你可以付钱给他们，这对他们来说也是一样的交易，你可以给他们钱，也可以给他们……
you know a piece of the company and they can sort of decide how much of either they want to take and then uh you're off you're up and running and you're a startup um then you go through some rounds um so the deal is you know eventually you'll burn through your say five million dollars You're up and running and you're a startup. Then you go through some rounds. So the deal is, you know, eventually you'll burn through your, say, $5 million. Like you'll spend it all. And then you'll say, okay, well, we have a good company, but, you know, we're not making enough money to cover our expenses yet. So then you go back to these venture capitalists and you say, look, I took your five million dollars and I built up this company and the company last year made let's say half a million dollars so what I do need now is I need ten million dollars so that I can like continue to expand the company and this this and this and this and this reason
公司的一部分股份，他们可以决定想要多少。然后你就开始运营了，你就是一家初创公司。然后你会经历几轮融资。所以交易是，最终你会烧掉那 500 万美元。你开始运营了，你就是一家初创公司。然后你会经历几轮融资。所以交易是，最终你会烧掉那 500 万美元。比如你花光了所有钱。然后你会说：“好吧，我们有一家好公司，但我们还没有赚到足够的钱来支付开支。”所以你回到这些风险投资家那里说：“看，我拿了你的 500 万美元，建立了这家公司，公司去年赚了 50 万美元。我现在需要 1000 万美元，这样我就可以继续扩大公司，因为这个、这个、这个原因……”
is why you know I'm gonna turn a profit and all that stuff and so they give you some more money to build a bigger company and uh you know at some point you become very big and you become sustainable so for example like look at uh uber for example so uber is still a startup technically because you know they haven't ipo'd um or anything like that um but uber is as far as i know is actually i don't know for a fact but i believe they just closed a new round all right oh they closed i think it's one of the probably not this is careful right so like there's always a trade-off between how fast you grow and you know funding your growth from your profits so i i believe i'm correct in saying that i think uber has continued to raise more uh investment capital uh to be able
这就是为什么我会盈利。所以他们给你更多的钱来建立一家更大的公司。在某个时候，你变得非常大，变得可持续。例如，看看 Uber。Uber 在技术上仍然是一家初创公司，因为他们还没有 IPO。但我所知，Uber 刚刚完成了新一轮融资。好吧，他们完成了，我想这可能是……小心点，对吧？在增长速度和利用利润资助增长之间总是存在权衡。我相信我是对的，Uber 继续筹集了更多的投资资本，以便……
to expand even faster to have a first mover advantage so basically they're trying to get to as many stories as possible as many cities as possible and so they could slow down with the cities they are and be essentially profitable but it costs a lot of money for them to roll out in a new city and so they'd rather keep bringing on new cities rather than getting profitable and they're like one of the most well-funded startups in history so like they have been given like their investors agree with them basically and and that's what they've chosen to do so yeah what patrick is saying like another part of that is you know and groupon has this as well is is um or had this is uh it's very hard to sort of i mean you hear a lot about patent trolls and patent lawsuits and things like that but in general if
能够扩张得更快，以获得先发优势。所以基本上，他们试图进入尽可能多的城市。他们可以放慢在现有城市的扩张速度，本质上实现盈利，但在新城市推广需要花费大量资金。所以他们宁愿继续进入新城市，而不是实现盈利。他们是历史上资金最充足的初创公司之一。所以他们的投资者基本上同意他们的做法，这就是他们选择做的。所以，Patrick 所说的，另一部分是，Groupon 也有这种情况，或者曾经有过，很难……我的意思是，你听说了很多关于专利流氓和专利诉讼的事情，但总的来说，如果……
you have a business idea it's pretty easy to copy and it's also very hard to shut down clones especially clones in other countries and things like that so a company like uber they have a good idea they need to get their idea in as many cities as possible so that there isn't like a detroit version of uber you know run by a different company a houston version of uber so on and so forth so that they can own all of the cities right and so to patrick's point like it might be more important to own all of the cities so there's only one uber even if it's like going to take a ton of money and then they can make that money up later um so yeah so that part is pretty complicated. At some point, your startup becomes pretty big. And then, actually, let me step back a bit. So there's multiple ways for your startup to not become a startup.
你有一个商业想法，它很容易被复制，而且很难关闭克隆版，特别是在其他国家的克隆版。所以像 Uber 这样的公司，他们有一个好主意，他们需要让他们的想法进入尽可能多的城市，这样就不会出现底特律版的 Uber，或者休斯顿版的 Uber，这样他们就可以拥有所有的城市。所以回到 Patrick 的观点，拥有所有的城市可能更重要，这样就只有一个 Uber，即使这需要花费大量的钱，他们以后也可以赚回来。所以那部分相当复杂。在某个时候，你的初创公司会变得相当大。其实，让我退后一步。初创公司不再是初创公司有多种方式。
The most common is it dissolves. So I think it's like over 90% of startups fail. And the number one reason they fail is actually in fighting. So the people who work at the startup, you know, clearly the people work at the startup believe in the startup to varying degrees, and are invested in the startup to varying degrees, you know, some of them are getting a bigger salary, but are getting less, you know, portion of the company as a result. And so that creates a lot of tension.
最常见的是它解散了。我认为超过 90% 的初创公司失败了。他们失败的首要原因是内斗。在初创公司工作的人，显然对初创公司的信念程度不同，投入程度也不同。有些人拿的薪水更高，但得到的公司股份更少。这造成了很多紧张关系。
And so actually the number one reason why startups fail is that the people, there's social problems and the startup falls apart. Of the startups that succeed, there's two major categories. One is, and this is for more of like startups that are more technology and less of like a product um is that the startup gets acquired by a bigger company so let's say you know i make a startup where i do statistics for people where i built like some cool statistics system um that isn't really a company like i couldn't go to patrick and sell them statistics like it's really like a business service well and so it is a company and you can make money but jason's talking a lot about venture capital and it's hard for them they want to recoup a lot of
所以初创公司失败的首要原因是社会问题，公司分崩离析。在成功的初创公司中，有两大类。一类是，这更多是针对技术型而非产品型的初创公司，即初创公司被大公司收购。假设我做了一个初创公司，我为人们做统计，我构建了一个很酷的统计系统。那不是一家真正的公司，我不能去找 Patrick 把统计数据卖给他们。所以它是一家公司，你可以赚钱。但 Jason 谈了很多关于风险投资的内容，这对他们来说很难，他们想快速收回……
money quickly and so they're taking a lot of bets and they don't want to bet on someone who says over the next 10 years i'm going to make a million dollars each year but not grow i'm just going to keep making a million dollars like i don't have a business plan i don't want to make a billion dollars i just want to keep making a million dollars every year forever yeah that's true that's true they're not really interested in gaining just a percentage of profits each year they want you to have an exit they want you to as jason's saying sell out to another company or he'll talk about the other option right right like most of the time I mean there are exceptions obviously but most of the time if I if I if a company gets acquired it's because it has some kind
资金，所以他们下了很多赌注。他们不想押注于那些说“未来 10 年我每年赚 100 万美元，但不增长，我只是继续每年赚 100 万美元，我没有商业计划，我不想赚 10 亿，我只想每年赚 100 万”的人。是的，那是真的。他们对每年只获得利润百分比不感兴趣，他们希望你有一个退出机制。他们希望你像 Jason 所说的那样卖给另一家公司，或者他会谈论另一种选择。没错，大多数时候，我的意思是显然有例外，但大多数时候，如果一家公司被收购，是因为它有某种……
of service and you know usually if a company IPOs, it's usually like a product. It could be like a product that serves businesses, but sort of a very well-defined product. But if it's like a service, like we do machine learning services to other companies, that usually turns into an acquisition. So let me explain both of them. So an acquisition just means, you know, a bigger company says, hey, look, here's the startup. It is like, you know, say eight people. They're all really talented and they all work together and they're not fighting. They haven't destroyed each other. So, you know, it'd be great if we could get eight people who are all very talented to work at our big company. Like, it'd be awesome. We could just put them in a team together and we know there's not going to be any problems. So they'll say, you know, let's buy the
服务。通常如果一家公司 IPO，它通常是一个产品。它可能是一个服务于企业的业务产品，但定义非常明确。但如果它是一种服务，比如我们为其他公司提供机器学习服务，那通常会导致收购。让我解释一下这两者。收购只是意味着一家大公司说：“嘿，看，这是那家初创公司。它有 8 个人，他们都非常有才华，他们一起工作，没有内斗。他们没有摧毁彼此。所以，如果我们能让 8 个非常有才华的人在我们的大公司工作，那就太棒了。我们可以把他们放在一个团队里，我们知道不会有任何问题。”所以他们会说：“让我们买下……”
startup. And so they might make a pretty big investment. Like they might spend like, say, 20 or even a hundred million dollars and they buy the startup. But what they're really buying is they're buying those people. Like they know that some of the people on that startup will stay at the big company. Some of them will leave because you can't force someone to work for you. But some of them will stay. And they have a very cohesive team.
初创公司。他们可能会进行相当大的投资，比如花费 2000 万甚至 1 亿美元买下初创公司。但他们真正买的是那些人。他们知道初创公司里的一些人会留在大公司。有些人会离开，因为你不能强迫别人为你工作。但有些人会留下。他们有一个非常有凝聚力的团队。
And they'll usually work something in writing where everyone has to stay for at least a couple of years and things like that. That's an acquisition. Another way that a startup can not be a startup is through what's called an IPO. And that's where a startup becomes a publicly traded company. So do you want to explain this? You'll probably be better than me.
他们通常会签署书面协议，每个人至少要留任几年之类的。这就是收购。初创公司不再是初创公司的另一种方式是通过所谓的 IPO。这就是初创公司成为上市公司的地方。你想解释一下吗？你可能比我更擅长。
Sure. IPO is an initial public offering. And that basically says that you're going to divide up the company into certain percentage shares and you're going to offer those to the public and there's all sorts of rules about how you can do this and if you look at an example like facebook is kind of the most recent famous one but tesla as well so these are often traded to a small number of people initially on what's called a secondary market, a closed market, where you have to meet certain criteria in order to be able to trade. In other words, not everyone can buy Facebook shares. You have to be an investor, basically.
当然。IPO 是首次公开募股。这基本上意味着你将公司分成一定比例的股份，并将其提供给公众。关于如何做到这一点有各种各样的规则。如果你看看 Facebook 这样的例子，它是最近比较著名的，还有特斯拉。这些股份最初通常只交易给少数人，在所谓的二级市场，即封闭市场，你必须满足特定标准才能进行交易。换句话说，不是每个人都能买 Facebook 的股票。你基本上必须是一名投资者。
Then they decide to IPO, which means that there's no company. They either just want to or there's no company big enough to buy them or no company that's interested in paying on their terms, whatever the reason may be. They decide that they were just going to sell some portion of the percentage to the public. And so they do what's called initial public offering. And you work through an investment bank to handle all sorts of complication and going to various retirement funds and getting them to agree to buy portions of facebook and uh you know all this stuff but basically what's going to happen is that uh it'll be regulated it'll be known you're going to declare uh here's all my earnings now because before you kept them private and you agree to all this stuff and say now the
然后他们决定 IPO，这意味着没有公司。他们要么只是想这样做，要么没有足够大的公司买下他们，或者没有公司有兴趣按他们的条件支付，无论原因是什么。他们决定只向公众出售一部分股份。所以他们进行了所谓的首次公开募股。你通过一家投资银行来处理各种复杂情况，并去各种退休基金，让他们同意购买 Facebook 的部分股份。基本上会发生的是，它将受到监管，它将是公开的，你将申报“这是我所有的收益”，因为之前你是保密的。你同意所有这些，说现在……
public can buy and sell you know a share of share of Facebook. And for all those, say you sell, I'm going to sell 20% of the company and, you know, 20 shares. So basically each share is 1% of the company and Facebook keeps 80 of them and sells 20 of them to the public. And they raise money by the people buying them at whatever the initial offer price is. Right, Exactly. So, and then after, from then on, when it's traded,
公众可以买卖 Facebook 的股票。对于所有这些，假设你出售，我要出售公司 20% 的股份，20 股。所以基本上每股是公司的 1%。Facebook 保留 80 股，向公众出售 20 股。他们通过人们以初始发行价购买这些股票来筹集资金。没错，完全正确。所以，在那之后，当它被交易时，
like if you go into your brokerage account and you buy Facebook right now, Facebook doesn't get any money from that. Unless you happen to be, unless it happens to be that a person at Facebook is selling you that share, but most likely, you know, like Jason could sell me that share of Facebook. It's not coming from that company more. So they don't continue to make money off of those shares right so what
如果你进入你的经纪账户购买 Facebook，Facebook 不会从中得到任何钱。除非碰巧是 Facebook 的人在向你出售那股股票，但最有可能的是，比如 Jason 可以把那股 Facebook 卖给我。它不再来自那家公司。所以他们不会继续从这些股票中赚钱。没错，所以……
happens if like if you buy all the shares and you just own the company like no because they don't offer the whole company so like in the case of facebook mark zuckerberg now has the equivalent since after the initial public offering he owns we could look it up because it has to be public but like let's say he still owns 30 of the shares um but then his shares may be special shares where he gets like two times the number of votes so he may get like you know essentially whatever that would be works out to be but he would get you know more votes for his 30 of the shares uh shares than the rest of people. Or some combination of people basically hold. So in the simplest case where you don't do vote multiplying,
如果如果你买下所有股票，你就拥有了公司，会发生什么？不，因为他们不提供整个公司。比如 Facebook 的情况，马克·扎克伯格现在拥有相当于……在首次公开募股后，他拥有……我们可以查一下，因为它必须是公开的。但假设他仍然拥有 30% 的股份，但他的股份可能是特殊股份，他可以获得两倍的投票权。所以他可能会获得……基本上无论那是什么，但他会为他的 30% 股份获得比其他人更多的投票权。或者人们基本上持有某种组合。在最简单的情况下，如果你不进行投票权倍增，
it's that Mark Zuckerberg and whoever his other co-founders are own 51% of the shares, and they only ever release 49% to be sold. Gotcha. Gotcha. So that's how they maintain ownership and then there's all sorts of clever ways to kind of keep ownership without having to own all the stock keep control i should say gotcha that makes sense so yeah so um that's how so yeah so that's startups in nutshell i mean it's it's it's it's known for being a lot of work for very little pay. But you're looking at the total expected value.
那就是马克·扎克伯格和其他联合创始人拥有 51% 的股份，他们只释放 49% 供出售。明白了。明白了。这就是他们保持所有权的方式，还有各种巧妙的方法来保持所有权，而不必拥有所有股票，我应该说保持控制权。明白了，这很有道理。所以，这就是初创公司的简要介绍。我的意思是，它以工作量大、报酬少而闻名。但你是在看总预期价值。
So you're hoping that if there's some kind of acquisition or something like that, that you can, like what they call cash out. So you might work for, you know, one fourth of what you could make as a regular employee at another company, but you also own, let's say, 1% of the company. And so then if the company becomes as big as Facebook, now you own 1% of $40 billion, which is what? $400 million. Which is a lot of money. So you're taking a chance. You're sacrificing your pay for a chance to do really well. And, I mean, statistically speaking, you won't do as well as a Facebook or Google,
所以你希望如果发生某种收购之类的，你可以“套现”。所以你可能工作量是你在另一家公司作为普通员工的四分之一，但你也拥有公司 1% 的股份。如果公司变得像 Facebook 那么大，现在你拥有 400 亿美元的 1%，也就是 4 亿美元。这是一大笔钱。所以你在冒险。你牺牲了薪水来换取成功的机会。我的意思是，从统计学上讲，你不会像 Facebook 或 Google 那样成功，
which is highly unlikely. But, again, if it's something you really believe will be successful and it will be like a acquire or something like that, uh, uh, acquisition or something like that, then, uh, um, then, you know, you could do really well. I mean, if you knew for sure that you would get acquired or IPO, if that was a guarantee that then you, then you would work there. Like, like we would all be working at startups. No, no, no, no, no.
这极不可能。但是，同样，如果这是你真正相信会成功的事情，并且会像收购之类的，那么，你可能会做得很好。我的意思是，如果你确定会被收购或 IPO，如果那是一个保证，那么你就会在那里工作。就像我们都会在初创公司工作一样。不，不，不，不，不。
It was a guarantee. work there like like we would all be working at startups no no no no guarantee you're yeah the the entire the incentives would be structured differently and you wouldn't get the same payout you're absolutely right so what i'm saying is like uh yeah if if there was a guarantee that it could ipo and you were getting like like one or two percent of the company or something like that then everyone would do it but yeah then to pat's point, like once a company is like Uber, where everyone knows it's going to be successful, then they know that there isn't a risk. And so then there's no reason. You get directly less percentage of the company at that point. Right. But it can still be really profitable because a lot of times they still really need people and so yeah they're willing to it's it is easier for them to give stock than dollars
这是一个保证。在那里工作，就像我们都会在初创公司工作一样。不，不，不，不，没有保证。你的整个激励机制结构会不同，你不会得到同样的报酬。你是绝对正确的。所以我想说的是，如果保证可以 IPO，并且你得到公司 1% 或 2% 的股份，那么每个人都会这样做。但回到 Patrick 的观点，一旦公司像 Uber 那样，每个人都知道它会成功，那么他们就知道没有风险。所以就没有理由了。那时你得到的公司百分比会直接减少。没错。但它仍然可能非常有利可图，因为很多时候他们仍然非常需要人，所以他们愿意……用股票支付比用美元支付更容易。
right right so you still can like i have no idea but i assume now you can probably still get a pretty good deal going to uber uh and getting stock because they're more easily payable to you in stock than than them but then you're having to hope that by the time you can actually sell that stock, that it'll be worth more than what it is now, which is essentially nothing because you can't sell it. Yeah, right. Yeah. That's another thing.
没错，所以你仍然可以……我不知道，但我假设现在去 Uber 仍然可以得到一个不错的交易，获得股票，因为他们用股票支付比用美元支付更容易。但你必须希望在你真正能卖掉那些股票的时候，它的价值会比现在高，而现在它基本上什么都不是，因为你卖不掉。是的，没错。那是另一回事。
That's actually good to talk about is it's very hard to know the value of a non-public company. And we've seen this right like with Facebook you know when Facebook had the IPO they IPO it and I'm gonna get this wrong but I mean is it roughly like thirty or forty dollars a share which means you take say thirty dollars and you multiply by the number of shares and that's how much you know they think that Facebook as a company is worth but then like within a month they ended up at I think it was like twelve dollars a share so what that means is that the public thought Facebook was worth one-third of what Facebook thought they were worth and I mean it's more
谈谈这个其实很好，因为很难知道非上市公司价值多少。我们已经看到了，比如 Facebook，当 Facebook IPO 时，他们 IPO 了，我可能会弄错，但我的意思是，大约是每股 30 或 40 美元，这意味着你拿 30 美元乘以股票数量，这就是他们认为 Facebook 作为一家公司价值多少。但一个月内，他们最终跌到了每股 12 美元。所以这意味着公众认为 Facebook 的价值只有 Facebook 自己认为的三分之一。我的意思是，这更……
complicated than that but but in a nutshell what that means is you know the people who were at facebook before they went public thought they were getting a certain amount of like they thought that they were worth something like their shares and everything and then within a month of the ipo they they found out that the shares are actually worth a third of what everyone thought they were worth and so there's a lot of uncertainty but um you know because of that risk um you know startups will give you more uh shares and things like that because they know you're taking on a risk that other people aren't willing to take so good all right i think it's time to move on to the news
复杂，但简而言之，这意味着在上市之前在 Facebook 的人认为他们得到了一定数量的……他们认为他们拥有价值，比如他们的股票等等。然后在 IPO 一个月内，他们发现股票的价值实际上只有大家认为的三分之一。所以有很多不确定性。但因为那种风险，初创公司会给你更多的股票之类的，因为他们知道你在承担别人不愿意承担的风险。所以，好的，我想是时候进入新闻环节了。
okay so i got the first one this came from a reader bentz and he sent us this is it's kind of interesting if you have a github account and someone uh makes a pull request against your repo repository i don't know i'm probably getting the exact wrong because i use too many different tools um but that basically when that email comes in now in gmail it'll actually give you a little button on the side of the subject line that allows you to directly go and view it uh so essentially there's now integration between gmail and github uh for viewing uh updates and stuff that they come in that's awesome is that like uh did they have to work with the gmail team or is there like an api or something i was actually just wondering that and i clicked on i don and I don't know.
好的，我先来。这是来自读者 Bentz 的，他发给我们这个，如果你的 GitHub 账户有人对你的仓库发起拉取请求（Pull Request），我不知道，我可能说得不对，因为我使用的工具太多了。但基本上，当那封邮件进来时，现在在 Gmail 中，它实际上会在主题行旁边给你一个小按钮，允许你直接去查看它。所以本质上，现在 Gmail 和 GitHub 之间有了集成，用于查看进来的更新之类的。太棒了。他们是必须与 Gmail 团队合作，还是有 API 之类的？我其实刚才就在想这个问题，我点击了……我不知道。
Oh, okay. Well, they're probably... I think it's like a way for the GitHub embed something in their email basically that tells like, hey, there's this thing, Gmail, this is how you render it or whatever. Gotcha. That makes sense. But because Gmail is so big, I guess it's worth it and so many github users use gmail but like you would probably
哦，好吧。嗯，它们可能是……我觉得这就像是 GitHub 在他们的电子邮件中嵌入了某种东西，基本上就是告诉 Gmail：“嘿，有这个东西，这是你渲染它的方式”之类的。明白了。这说得通。但因为 Gmail 太大了，我想这是值得的，而且这么多 GitHub 用户都在用 Gmail，但你可能
have to do something different like there's no standard i don't think so like they wouldn't now also get something in yahoo yeah right right yeah um cool so yeah my news is on rust so actually i we should cover this. This is a brand new, well, sorry, it's a brand new language to me. But I read about it when I saw this news article. So, the news article is Rust 0.12.0 is released. And so, I was looking into Rust, and I'm not going to say too much because we should dedicate a show to it. But basically, it's a language that's intended to be very fast for system software-y stuff, like C or C++.
得做点不同的事情，比如没有标准，我不这么认为，所以他们现在也不会在 Yahoo 里得到什么，是啊，对，对，嗯，酷。所以，我的新闻是关于 Rust 的，实际上我——我们应该讨论一下这个。这是一个全新的，嗯，抱歉，对我来说是一个全新的语言。但我看到这篇新闻文章时读到了它。所以，新闻文章是 Rust 0.12.0 发布了。所以，我研究了一下 Rust，我不会说太多，因为我们应该专门做一期节目来讨论它。但基本上，它是一种旨在为系统软件方面的东西提供非常快速度的语言，就像 C 或 C++。
But the compiler is very, very smart. And they've reduced sort of what you can do a little bit although it's it's it's almost as fully functional as fully featured as you know crc plus plus they just they just handicap you a tiny bit but in exchange the compiler is actually extremely clever and uh i think it's pretty cool i'm going to do more research into it and we'll have a whole show dedicated to it but uh but yeah you know take some time and check it out if you're into doing low level you know c c++ tasks um this could be uh really cool so and it compiles to like machine code and all of that so if that's important yeah so the next one is about uh intel processors underestimating the error bounds of sine. I think it might just be trigonometric functions in general by 1.3 quintillion.
但编译器非常、非常聪明。他们稍微减少了你可以做的事情，尽管它几乎和 C/C++ 一样功能齐全，功能丰富，他们只是稍微限制了你一点，但作为交换，编译器实际上非常聪明，呃，我觉得它很酷，我会做更多的研究，我们会专门做一期节目来讨论它，但呃，但是的，你知道，花点时间看看它，如果你喜欢做底层，你知道，C/C++ 任务，呃，这可能呃真的很酷，所以它编译成机器码之类的，所以如果这很重要的话，是的，所以下一个是关于呃英特尔处理器低估了正弦函数的误差范围。我觉得可能只是三角函数一般都会有 1.3 亿亿的误差。
Yeah, a little bit of sensationalism. Yeah. So what this is, there will be a link or you may have already seen or you'll be able to search for it. But so interestingly, you design a processor out of silicone silicon and um they you know it's kind of there forever it just stuck with whatever is there and intel has some had some famous kind of problems and what happens when things go wrong or what inputs and this one's a little more subtle and it's apparently been around for several years and the documentation around the various functions are incorrect and one of it is that i believe it's actually in the processor as far as i could tell when i was reading it now now
是的，有点耸人听闻。是的。所以这是什么，会有一个链接，或者你可能已经看到了，或者你将能够搜索到它。但有趣的是，你用硅设计了一个处理器，呃，你知道它基本上就永远在那里了，它就被困在任何现有的东西里，英特尔有一些著名的那种问题，当事情出错时会发生什么，或者什么输入，而这个更微妙一些，而且显然已经存在好几年了，围绕各种函数的文档是不正确的，其中之一是我相信它实际上是在处理器中，据我阅读时所知，现在现在
i'm thinking like i wonder because intel actually also makes a compiler um for their processors so i hope i hope i'm right in saying this is actually the processor because i read it with an assumption okay good you're right because i read it with an assumption and now i was like oh no maybe i okay anyways uh and so basically the interesting part of this is that when you do a sign of a number um that number could be pretty much you know the input could be anything so in in double or flow whatever the range of inputs is as big as you can support in doubles and obviously you really only want to define sine as a function of just like the first repeating interval or some repeating interval so
我在想，我想知道，因为英特尔实际上也为他们的处理器制作了一个编译器，所以我希望我说是处理器是对的，因为我带着假设读了它，好吧，很好，你是对的，因为我带着假设读了它，现在我在想，哦不，也许我，好吧，无论如何，呃，所以基本上这部分有趣的是，当你做一个数字的正弦时，那个数字几乎可以是，你知道，输入可以是任何东西，所以在双精度或浮点数中，无论输入范围有多大，只要双精度能支持，显然你真的只想把正弦定义为仅仅是第一个重复区间或某个重复区间的函数，所以
you want to take whatever the input is and essentially wrap it around because sine is periodic right so sine keeps repeating itself so you want to reduce whatever the input is and essentially wrap it around because sine is periodic, right? So sine keeps repeating itself. So you want to reduce the input to something that's in a very specific range and then give a really precise answer in that range. Else you're forced trying to represent the infinite part of sine out and it gets really complicated. And this is actually a really common technique for a lot of things where you have a number that doesn't overflow or have a limit but actually just keeps wrapping around and defining that wraparound function and it turns out that there was a problem when you give a number that is very close to sign or to pi very close to pi in the input and they had not as many bits of precision as they thought they had and so what it causes like a
你想要获取任何输入，并基本上将其环绕，因为正弦是周期性的，对吧？所以正弦会不断重复自己，所以你想要减少输入，并基本上将其环绕，因为正弦是周期性的，对吧？所以正弦会不断重复自己。所以你想要将输入减少到某个非常特定的范围内，然后在该范围内给出一个非常精确的答案。否则你被迫试图表示正弦的无限部分，这会变得非常复杂。这实际上是一种非常常见的技术，用于很多事情，当你有一个不会溢出或没有限制，但实际上只是不断环绕的数字时，定义那个环绕函数，结果发现当你给出一个非常接近正弦或圆周率的数字时，输入非常接近圆周率，而他们没有他们认为拥有的那么多位精度，所以它导致了一个
whole like the output basically is far less precise than it should have been and it's actually in the silicon because of the way they're reducing that input the way they're trying to wrap it around yeah exactly yeah you end up with what's called catastrophic cancellation which is an awesome name. But basically, it just means, if you try to subtract two numbers, that so in other words, so just a quick recap on floating point, right? The way floating point works is a little more complicated than this, but let's just simplify it. Imagine if you had, say, a number, like,, 0.12345, right? So you could just represent that in floating point by saying 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 times 10 to the negative, you know, sixth or whatever it is, right? So that's sort of what they do. So they end up with
整体，输出基本上远没有它应该有的那么精确，而且它实际上是在硅片中，因为他们减少输入的方式，他们试图环绕它的方式，是的，完全正确，是的，你最终得到了所谓的灾难性抵消，这是一个很棒的名字。但基本上，它只是意味着，如果你试图减去两个数字，那么换句话说，所以关于浮点数的快速回顾，对吧？浮点数的工作方式比这更复杂，但让我们简化一下。想象一下，如果你有，比如说，一个数字，像 0.12345，对吧？所以你可以通过说 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 乘以 10 的负，你知道，六次方或无论它是什么，来在浮点数中表示它，对吧？所以这基本上就是他们所做的。所以他们最终得到
like a regular number and then they store an exponent. Now in their case, they do times 2 to the whatever, but let's just pretend it's 10 to make life easy. So if you have like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, and then another number that's like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 7, then when you subtract those two, all of those first numbers are going to go to zero and the difference is going to be one right so that's going to cause like your exponent to change a lot too right like you can think in your head like think you have these two big numbers but now
像一个常规数字，然后他们存储一个指数。现在在他们的情况下，他们做的是乘以 2 的多少次方，但让我们假装它是 10 以简化生活。所以如果你有像 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6，然后另一个数字是像 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 7，那么当你减去这两个时，所有那些前面的数字都将变为零，差值将是 1，对吧？所以这也将导致你的指数发生很大变化，对吧？就像你可以在脑海中想象，你认为你有这两个大数字，但现在
you subtracted them and you end up with this little number and so actually the little number you kind of have a lot of room to the right like if there were other numbers it was one two three four five six dot like point seven eight nine ten eleven or seventy nine nine nine nine nine you know those things after the dot become important like before it would they were small because you're this huge number and then dot and this tiny piece onto it, right? But as soon as you subtract two huge numbers, then the tiny pieces after the dot, all of a sudden they're important. But if you got rid of them because the number was big and they weren't important, so you chopped them off,
你减去了它们，你最终得到了这个小数字，所以实际上这个小数字你有点像在右边有很多空间，如果还有其他数字，它是 1 2 3 4 5 6 点 7 8 9 10 11 或 79 9 9 9 9，你知道，小数点后的那些东西变得很重要，就像之前它们很小，因为你是一个巨大的数字，然后点，这个微小的部分在上面，对吧？但一旦你减去两个巨大的数字，那么小数点后的微小部分，突然间它们就变得很重要了。但如果你因为数字很大而摆脱了它们，它们不重要，所以你把它们切掉了，
it's like you chopped off something that wasn't important, but it became important later and that's called catastrophic cancellation and so and that's really bad right and so that's exactly what happens when you take a sign of a number close to pi so yeah and so the reason you get such a large thing is because when you're dealing with 64-bit numbers it's very easy to quickly escalate things to the point where you have this quintillion counts of error or whatever yeah yep yeah exactly um math cool hard especially point stuff yeah floating point stuff is just total nightmare it's just tricky there's a lot of corner cases. It's really hard to test very well. Yeah, yeah, definitely.
这就像你切掉了一些不重要的东西，但它后来变得很重要了，这被称为灾难性抵消，所以，这真的很糟糕，对吧？所以当你取一个接近圆周率的数字的正弦时，这正是发生的事情，所以是的，所以你得到这么大误差的原因是因为当你处理 64 位数字时，很容易迅速升级到你拥有这种亿亿级误差的地步，或者无论什么，是的，是的，完全正确，嗯，数学很酷，很难，特别是浮点数的东西，是的，浮点数的东西简直是噩梦，它只是很棘手，有很多极端情况。真的很难测试得很好。是的，是的，绝对。
Yeah, it's like deceptively simple. Like you think it's an easy idea. Like, okay, we'll just take the first few digits and then we'll put 10 to the whatever. Like we've been doing scientific notation since we were in sixth grade or whatever. So you think it's going to be easy, but then the problem is computers are like
是的，它看起来简单得令人困惑。就像你认为这是一个简单的想法。就像，好吧，我们只取前几位数字，然后我们放 10 的多少次方。就像我们从六年级开始就一直在做科学计数法一样，所以你认为这会很容易，但问题是计算机就像
doing so much math on the same number that uh even if you make like there's a tiny little approximation it can burn you that's what happens here and like you point out there's all sorts of cases where like in actual math the order of operations doesn't matter but in floating point math it does matter so like if you multiply a very large number by a very large number by a very tiny number like the order the associative rule of how you actually do that will change your answer yep yep and you have to be aware of that yep and even people who are trying to do it really well still end up doing it wrong sometimes yeah yeah definitely um cool so uh yes it's other news it's uh this is only for students unfortunately but if you are a student at high school university i think any any institution
在同一个数字上做太多的数学运算，以至于即使你做了一个微小的近似，它也会烧毁你，这就是这里发生的事情，就像你指出的那样，有各种各样的情况，比如在实际数学中，运算顺序并不重要，但在浮点数学中，它确实很重要，所以如果你用一个非常大的数字乘以一个非常大的数字，再乘以一个非常小的数字，比如你实际做这件事的结合律顺序会改变你的答案，是的，是的，你必须意识到这一点，是的，即使是那些试图做得非常好的人有时最终还是会做错，是的，是的，绝对，嗯，酷，所以，是的，其他新闻，这是不幸的，这只针对学生，但如果你是高中、大学的学生，我想任何机构
is fine um then you can get the github student developer pack which looks pretty freaking amazing um it is just a huge laundry list of things that you get for free um so yeah you get like crowdsourcing from crowdflower uh you know you get a you get a pro github account um you get the unreal engine um you get send grid to like programmatically send emails. You just get a ton of amazing stuff for completely free for no cost as long as you can prove you're a student.
都可以，那么你可以获得 GitHub 学生开发者包，看起来非常棒，它只是你免费获得的一大堆东西的清单，所以是的，你得到像来自 Crowdflower 的众包，你知道，你得到一个 GitHub 专业账户，你得到虚幻引擎，你得到 SendGrid 来以编程方式发送电子邮件。只要你能证明你是学生，你就能完全免费获得大量令人惊叹的东西，无需任何费用。
Pretty freaking awesome. If you are a student and you're listening to us, you're high school, college, whatever, get this. Sign up for this. It is incredible. Another thing, a little bit of a side note, but Amazon has something similar, and get that one too. You get, like, free, you know, computers, like, free virtual machines on Amazon.
非常棒。如果你是学生，并且你在听我们节目，你是高中生、大学生，无论什么，得到这个。注册这个。这太不可思议了。另一件事，一个小小的旁注，但亚马逊也有类似的东西，也得到那个。你得到，像，免费的，你知道，计算机，像，在亚马逊上的免费虚拟机。
Yeah, AWS, whatever. Yeah, yeah. So check that out. Cool. All right. It's time for Book of the Show. Book of the Show. So my book is called Impro for Storytellers.
是的，AWS，无论什么。是的，是的。所以去看看那个。酷。好的。现在是节目之书的时间。节目之书。所以我的书叫《Impro for Storytellers》。
It's pretty cool. It's this guy. He's a famous, or I guess not famous, but he's a very experienced improvisational instructor. And so he does a lot of like corporate events and things like that he also you know teaches uh you know people who have gone on to work at saturday night live or write for saturday night live or things like that um and he wrote this book and he kind of intended it for everyone he has a similar book that's kind of meant for people who want to get into improvisational comedy which is for me not that interesting but but uh this book is really cool it's kind of meant for anyone and it just talks about sort of how to be improvisational
它很酷。是这个家伙。他是一位著名的，或者我想不是著名的，但他是一位非常有经验的即兴表演教练。所以他做了很多像企业活动之类的事情，他也你知道教那些后来去周六夜现场工作或为周六夜现场写作的人，或者类似的事情，他写了这本书，他有点打算把它写给每个人，他有一本类似的书，是专门为那些想进入即兴喜剧的人准备的，对我来说这没那么有趣，但呃，这本书真的很酷，它有点打算给任何人，它只是谈论如何即兴发挥
and how to think creatively and um how to sort of think on your feet and um it seems pretty cool i mean i've i haven't got into it yet i've only ordered it so um oh just like a preview yeah i'll have to give a recap but uh you know i i read through uh some of the preview of it and it's uh it looks pretty awesome and so yeah cool mine is of course not helpful it is just a science fiction book the androids dream which uh is by john scalzi a reference also to the philip k dick do androids dream of electric sheep i initially thought there was something weird going on there but is i think it's just an homage to the other work and then you make reference of it in the book uh and so um but it's not at all related as far as like the storylines uh and this is the first book
以及如何创造性地思考，以及如何即兴发挥，而且它看起来很酷，我的意思是，我还没有开始读，我只是订购了它，所以，哦，就像一个预览，是的，我得做一个回顾，但你知道，我读了一些它的预览，它看起来非常棒，所以是的，酷，我的当然没有帮助，它只是一本科幻书《The Android's Dream》，这是由约翰·斯卡尔齐写的，也是对菲利普·K·迪克的《仿生人会梦见电子羊吗？》的引用，我最初以为那里发生了一些奇怪的事情，但我认为这只是对另一部作品的致敬，然后在书中你提到了它，所以，但就故事情节而言，它完全没有关联，这是第一本书
by john scalzi i think i've read i may have read one other book by him um but he writes self-described by him as you know introductory science fiction so this is um much closer to just normal fiction but with science-y settings so i I often recommend books which are considered more hardcore science fiction, like very deep, all sorts of pseudoscience-y explanations for things and even real science or physics involved. This is really plausible. This is more just of a fun tale.
由约翰·斯卡尔齐写的，我想我读过，我可能读过他的另一本书，但他写的，被他自己描述为，你知道，入门级科幻小说，所以这比普通的虚构小说更接近，但有科学背景，所以我经常推荐被认为更硬核的科幻小说，比如非常深奥，各种伪科学的解释，甚至涉及真实的科学或物理学。这真的很合理。这更多只是一个有趣的故事。
I don't want to talk too much about it because I never want to spoil anything. But basically, this is just more of a fun tale. It's in a sort of a science fiction setting um and it was a pretty it was a it was a very i guess light read but it was very good i enjoyed it cool cool cool so if you've tried to get through some of the other very large tomes that i've recommended and you haven't uh try this one instead cool sounds good yeah give it a shot tool of the show tool of the show my tool of the show is what i'm using to stream to twitch right now which is called open broadcaster
我不想谈论太多，因为我从不想剧透任何东西。但基本上，这只是一个更有趣的故事。它是在一种科幻背景下，而且它是一个非常，我想是一个非常轻松的读物，但它非常好，我很喜欢它，酷，酷，酷，所以如果你尝试读完我推荐的其他一些非常大的大部头，而你没有，尝试这一本，酷，听起来不错，是的，试一试，节目工具，节目工具，我的节目工具是我现在用来流媒体到 Twitch 的东西，它叫 Open Broadcaster
software um so twitch actually recommended it you know i went to twitch trying to figure out how to stream um uh just to stream the show just kind of for kicks and uh they said hey use this program oh do we have any viewers of our stream we have one person oh yes hello person so calin444 uh major props to you for checking out the twitch stream you know i only gave people an hour's notice. I wasn't expecting a huge turnout or anything like that. The thing that I really think is cool about Twitch is the chat, actually.
Software，所以 Twitch 实际上推荐了它，你知道，我去了 Twitch，试图弄清楚如何流媒体，呃，只是为了流媒体节目，只是为了好玩，他们说嘿，使用这个程序，哦，我们有我们流媒体的观众吗？我们有一个人，哦，是的，你好，人，所以 Calin444，非常感谢你查看 Twitch 流媒体，你知道，我只提前一小时通知人们。我没指望会有很多人参加之类的。我真正认为关于 Twitch 很酷的事情实际上是聊天。
Actually, I was inspired to stream this because of our user question. Twitch plays Pokemon. Oh, God. A user question. The person said, what's it like to be in Silicon Valley Made me think we really should try to get A bit of a community going Where people who like the show
实际上，我受到启发来流媒体这个是因为我们的用户问题。Twitch 玩口袋妖怪。哦，天哪。一个用户问题。那个人说，在硅谷是什么感觉？让我觉得我们真的应该尝试建立一点社区，让那些喜欢这个节目的人
And listen to the show can meet each other Literally zero people And we have One person So Callan444 props to you Sorry you couldn't meet anyone But you can meet us uh for what it's worth um and uh yeah i mean we'll do this maybe you know a couple more shows and uh uh see see sort
并且听这个节目的人可以互相见面，字面上零个人，我们有一个人，所以 Callan444，向你致敬，抱歉你没能见到任何人，但你可以见到我们，呃，无论如何，呃，是的，我的意思是，我们可能会做这个，你知道，再做几期节目，呃，看看我们能得到什么样的参与度，但呃，但是的，所以我正在使用这个 Open Broadcaster Software，呃，呃，它很酷，设置起来实际上非常简单。它给我的唯一麻烦是我对设置做了一些更改，我必须关闭程序并重新启动它才能使更改生效，但我不知道我，你知道，他们没有告诉我重新启动程序。所以只是一个小瑕疵。但你知道，除此之外，它几乎开箱即用，呃，呃，是的，非常酷，非常酷的工具，而且他们
of what kind of turnout we get but uh but yeah so i'm using this open broadcaster software and uh um it's pretty cool it's actually pretty straightforward to set up. The only trouble it gave me was I made some changes to the settings and I had to shut down the program and restart it for the changes to take effect but I didn't know that I, you know, they didn't tell me to restart the program. So just a minor nit. But you know, other than that it pretty much worked out of the box and uh uh yeah pretty cool pretty cool tool um also they
有一个 Mac 版本，Linux 版本也即将推出，所以是的，酷，我的也是视频相关的，某种程度上，那就是 Plex，它在 plex.tv，或者我想你可以直接搜索 Plex，这是各种东西的组合，这我猜有点争议，但我很喜欢，这是一个服务器，你在上面运行，我想他们至少有 Windows 和 Linux，我运行 Windows 和 Linux 两个服务器，呃，客户端有一个网页界面，或者它也有 Android 应用程序，iOS 应用程序，无论你想要什么。它在 Chromecast 上工作，我有很多使用。它在 Chromecast 上工作。它所做的是，它将为你提供你所有的媒体，它做音频图片，视频，你有点运行服务器，你指向你存储媒体的地方。如果它是，例如，音乐，它将能够访问 IMDB，正确填充它，
have a version for mac and a version for linux is coming so yeah cool mine is also video related sort of and that is plex uh which is at plex.tv or i think you can just search plex and this is a combination of things uh which is i guess somewhat controversial but i enjoy it which is a server that you run on i think they have windows and linux at least i run both the windows and the linux ones servers and um a client has a web interface, or also it has Android apps, iOS apps, whatever you want. It works on I have a Chromecast. And that's how I use a lot. It works on the Chromecast. And what it does, it will serve you all of your media, it does audio pictures, videos, you kind of run the server, you point it at where your media is stored. And if it's, for instance, music, it'll be able to access IMDB, properly populate it,
给你所有我们期望的那种能力，从中搜索。至少我认为这很有效。然后如果你有像你的平板电脑或手机，并且你有应用程序，你知道，它能够从你的网络流式传输并流式传输过来。你说，嗯，嗯，有成千上万种方法可以做到这一点，我之前谈到过各种方法，UPnP 方法，DLNA 方法，呃，Plex 我认为实际上确实支持任何 DLNA 客户端，甚至可能是 UPnP 客户端，我不知道，呃，但它做的一件好事是它确实会处理转码，而且它是第一个
give you all the kind of what we come to expect ability to kind of search from it. At least I think that works well. And then if you have like your tablet or your phone and you have the app, you know, it's able to stream from your network and stream it across. You say, well well there's like a thousand ways to done this i've talked about various ways before upnp ways dlna ways um and plex i think actually does support uh any dlna client or maybe even upnp client i don't know um but the one nice things it does is it does will handle the transcoding and it's the first
我发现实际上只是工作的，所以它大部分是免费的，呃，他们有一些功能，比如投射到 Chromecast，实际上你必须付费才能获得该功能，呃，我有点感觉那是怎么工作的，就像他们怎么让你付费？所以如果你在应用程序中，实际上做投射，并且可能有绕过它的方法，但我没有费心，因为我想支持他们，呃，因为它实际上工作，而且当你，如果你没有用一个本质上是付费账户登录，它甚至不会给你投射的选项，或者如果你尝试投射，我想它会告诉你，哦，你需要升级之类的，它是月费吗？或者，是的，所以我实际上只是，这有点像我买了终身订阅
one i found that actually just works so it it is mostly free um they there are some features like casting to a chromecast they actually you have to pay to get that feature um and i kind of feel about how does that work like where do they how do they make you pay so if you have in the app that actually does the casting and there's probably ways around it but i i didn't bother with it because i wanted to support them uh because it actually works uh and when you it won't if you haven't uh signed in with a essentially a paid account it won't give you the option to cast either or if you try to cast i think it tells you like oh you need to upgrade or whatever how is it a monthly fee or yeah so i actually just uh this is kind of i bought like the lifetime subscription
我从来没有用过 Tivo，我们没有有线电视，所以我猜这就像我的一项有线电视替代费用，事情是，它可能最近涨价了，我看到了关于那的电子邮件，但我认为我一次付了 75 美元，哇，那太棒了，但这有点贵，就像它是 75 美元，而且有开源替代品，哦，好吧，那实际上很多，该死，但，但就像我说的，它只是工作，可能有其他方法可以做到，我喜欢在网上看，呃，并试图找到一种不付费的方法来做到这一点，就像每个优秀的软件工程师一样，是的，对，不，我不意味着像我试图窃取它，但我只是意味着像我试图看开源的，你知道，更原生的 Linux 的，而且有，但你知道，它们在 Chromecast 上真的不工作，它们真的不处理像
i've never had tivo and we don't have cable so i guess this is like my one of my cable replacement expenses um thing is like it might have recently gone up i saw emails about that but i think i paid like 75 once wow that's great but it's kind of pricey like it's 75 dollars and there are open source alternatives oh okay that's actually a lot dang um but but like i said it just works uh there's probably other ways of doing it and i like looked online um and you know tried to find a non-paying way of doing it like every good software engineer person yeah right not no i don't mean like i try to steal it but i just mean like i tried to like look at open source ones you know just like more native linux ones and there were but you know they don't really work on chromecast they don't really handle like
即时转码，它们对你知道你可以使用什么媒体很挑剔，无论什么，这个只是工作，而且对我来说工作得非常好，呃，而且好，这进入了那些呃，我不是律师，我不能建议你，你可能不应该。但我有一个朋友，你知道，有孩子，想能够停止不得不去拿出像卡通 DVD 给他们放。结果如果你在你的电脑上录制那些 DVD，如果有一种合法的方法可以做到这一点，而你做了，并且你使用这个将它们提供给你的电视，它使它很棒，因为呃，它会使它很棒，因为你然后不必去拿 DVD 并为你的孩子插入它们，当他们想要什么时，你实际上可以只给他们看所有封面的图片，并让他们选择
transcoding on the fly they're picky about you know what media you can use whatever this one just works and it works really well for me um and good this gets into one of those uh uh i'm not a lawyer i can't advise you you probably shouldn't. But I have a friend who, you know, has kids and wanted to be able to stop having to go pull out like DVDs of cartoons to stick on for them. And it turns out if you kind of record those DVDs on your computer and if there's a legal way to do that and you did that and you use this to serve them up to your TV, it makes great because uh it would make it great because you could then not have to go get the dvds and stick them in for your children when they wanted something you could actually just show them the pictures of all the covers and have them choose
他们想看哪一个，是的，这太棒了，我绝对得试试这个，他们有像免费的吗？等等，高级版又给你什么？所以我认为那只是如果你只如果你想，所以你可以安装服务器，看到它正确地拾取你的东西并通过网页界面流式传输它。然后它只是，如果你想 Chromecast 它，我想这是我唯一使用它的地方。哦，我明白了。它还为你提供了像做远程同步的能力。所以就像现在我有订阅了，我可以，我的手机可以把我的照片上传到
which one they wanted to watch yeah this is awesome i'm definitely gonna have to try this out do they have like a free wait what does the premium get you again so i think that's just if you only if you want to so you can install the server, see that it's correctly picking up your stuff and streaming it over the web interface. And then it's just, if you want to Chromecast it, I think is the only thing I use it for. Oh, I see. It also offers you the ability to like do remote syncing. So like now that I have the subscription, I can, my phone can upload my pictures to
我的服务器作为备份，自动地，呃，还有一些其他类似的功能，明白了，明白了，酷，那太棒了，是的，我今晚实际上要安装这个，好的，是的，好吧，让我知道，就像我甚至在节目中推荐过其他类似这个的，但这是我坚持使用的第一个，因为它实际上看起来工作得非常好，是的，是的，那听起来很棒，是的，我有一台插在电视上的 Linux 盒子，正在运行 Ubuntu，我绝对会安装这个。好的，是的。一点点题外话。
my server as backup, automatically uh and some other features like that gotcha gotcha cool that's awesome yeah i'm actually gonna install this tonight all right yeah well let me know like i've recommended even other ones similar to this on the show but this is the first one that i've stuck with because it actually seems to work really well yeah yeah that sounds awesome yeah i have a linux box that's plugged in the tv um that's running ubuntu that I'll definitely install this on. All right, yeah. A little bit of a tangent.
我在虚拟机上安装了 FreeBSD，就像虚拟机，只是为了看看。因为它一直出现。就像这个 Plex，他们有一个 FreeBSD 的二进制文件。它在工作中出现了，之类的事情。所以我当时想，看，让我看看这个。因为我从来没有完全理解 FreeBSD 到底是什么。而且再次，就像，我玩了它也许，你知道，一个小时。
I installed FreeBSD on a virtual box, like virtual machine, just to see. Because it keeps coming up. Like this Plex, they have a binary for FreeBSD. And it came up at work and things like that. And so I was like, look, let me just look at this. Because I never quite understood what FreeBSD really was. And again, like, I played with it for maybe, you know, an hour.
所以我仍然不太知道，你知道。我认为它和 Linux 之间的最大区别是许可证。所以换句话说，你可以商业化使用 FreeBSD，而且没关系。你甚至可以修改源代码而不贡献回去。我不知道。所以有某种政治原因让你想使用 FreeBSD。但它看起来似乎不如 Linux 好。这可能只是因为我习惯使用 Linux。
So I still don't really know, you know. I think it's like the big difference between it and Linux is the license. So in other words, you can use FreeBSD commercially and it's okay. You could even modify the source code and not contribute back. I don't know. So there's sort of like political reasons why you'd want to use FreeBSD. But it seems like just not as good as Linux. It could be just because I'm used to using Linux.
但是，例如，我做的第一件事是我尝试，你知道，sudo 一个命令，这样我就不必是 root。而 sudo，就像，在 FreeBSD 中不存在。有其他方法可以做到，是吗？是的，要么那样，要么你必须登录。所以我曾经沉迷于，像，Linux 发行版之类的，我放弃了，现在我只是在 Ubuntu 上，呃，同样的方式，这只是因为，就像，字面上只有一个原因，它不是哲学上的，政治上的，什么都不是，因为当我有问题时，我写在
But, like, for example, the first thing I did was I tried to, you know, sudo a command so that I didn't have to be root. And sudo, like, doesn't exist in FreeBSD. There's some other methodology for doing it, yeah? Yeah, either that or you have to log in. So I used to be into, like, Linux distributions and stuff, and I gave up, and now I'm just on ubuntu uh same way and it's just because like there's literally only one reason it isn't philosophical political nothing is because when i have a problem and i write in
Ubuntu 中，然后我的问题，我比任何其他发行版更有可能得到我的答案，是的，那听起来很可怕，我喜欢它，只是现在有足够多的人使用它，以至于我通常可以找到我的问题的答案，我不必发布我自己的东西，我不必像黑客一样折腾它一个小时，呃，如果有一些像，哦，你知道，就像你刚才谈到的 Open Broadcaster Software 将要有一个 Linux 版本，我知道他们很可能会有一个 Debian 或 Ubuntu 版本，因为它太受欢迎了，我可以安装它，而且几乎保证能工作，我记得像 Ubuntu 刚出来的时候，呃，就像立刻，它在用户友好性方面就比所有其他发行版优越得多
ubuntu and then my problem i'm most likely to get my answer than any other distribution yeah that's that's like it sounds horrible and i like it's just enough people use it now that like i can typically find an answer to my problem i don't have to post my own thing i don't have to like hack on it for an hour um if there's some like oh you know like you were talking earlier about open broadcaster software is going to have a linux i know they'll most likely have a debian or ubuntu version uh because it's so popular and i can just install it and it's almost guaranteed to work i remember like when ubuntu first came out and uh like right off the bat it was just so superior to all the other distributions in terms of its user friendliness
而且我记得就像立刻说，我当时正在使用，我想是 Gentoo，然后 Ubuntu 出来了，我就像，好吧，我完了，就像他们，我立刻转换了，而且你知道，他们一直在变得越来越好，而且你知道，Ubuntu 是，呃，呃，有一个巨大的，像，呃，呃，像投资者，它实际上是在，我想是南非制造的，或者至少是一个南非投资者拥有 Ubuntu 公司。所以它资金非常充足。而且我认为这就是它如此精致的原因。但无论如何，一点题外话。好的，我们进入时髦的语言。
and i remember like immediately saying like i was using i think gen 2 and ubuntu came out and i was like okay i'm done like they i immediately converted um and you know they just keep getting better and better and you know ubuntu is uh um has a huge like uh um like investor it's actually made in i think south africa or it's at least a South African investor who owns the Ubuntu company. And so it's just very well funded. And I think that's the reason why it's so polished. But anyways, a little digression. All right, we're on to funky languages.
时髦的语言。语言，所以每个人都拿出你的，呃，你知道，呃，喇叭裤和你的，你知道，爆炸头假发，而且你回到 70 年代，回到 70 年代，所以，呃，呃，所以是的，所以其中一个，我们只是会浏览它们，并，并，并，呃，并简要地谈论它们。所以我的最爱是，我的最爱之一是 Whitespace。而且这听起来完全一样。全是制表符。哦，首先，向建议这个的人致敬。我不记得是谁了，但有人写信告诉我们这样做。你知道你是谁。
Funky languages. languages so everyone get out your uh you know i don't know uh bell bottoms and your you know afro wigs and uh you're going back to the 70s going back to the 70s so uh uh so yeah so one of them we'll just kind of go through them and and and uh and talk about them briefly. So my favorite is, one of my favorites is Whitespace. And that's exactly how it sounds. It's all tabs. Oh, first of all, props to whoever suggested this. I don't remember who it is, but somebody wrote in and told us to do. You know who you are.
是的。所以向你致敬。我会看看是否有小休息，我可以查一下你。但这是一个很棒的节目想法。所以 Whitespace 全是制表符、空格和换行符。所以字面上，这就是语言。所以，你知道，像一个制表符意味着什么，两个连续的制表符意味着别的东西，你知道，以此类推。所以，你知道，显然你必须使用一个编辑器，它可以告诉你制表符在哪里
Yeah. So props to you. I'll see if there's a little break, I can look you up. But this is a great idea for a show. So whitespace is all tabs, spaces, and new lines. So literally, that is the language. So, you know, like one tab means something, two consecutive tabs means something else, you know, so on and so forth. So, you know, obviously you'll have to use an editor which can tell you where a tab is
相对于四个空格。所以你必须有一个，它会突出显示制表符。但除此之外，你知道，所有这些语言都是功能齐全的。就像你可以用它们写任何东西。它们是图灵完备的，但它们不一定是任何人会尝试用它们编写实际程序的语言。任何，除了好玩之外的任何东西。就像我们不认为这些在任何方面是富有成效或高效的时间利用。是的。是的。是的。就像不要在面试中提到这些。哦，好吧，所以，所以这个 Whitespace，我今天在工作中字面上进行了一次对话，呃，在，在工作的单位，当我们进行面试时，我们在白板或黑板上进行，
versus four spaces. So you have to have one that sort of highlights the tabs. But other than that, you know, all of these languages are fully functional. Like you could write anything to them. They're Turing complete, but they're not necessarily anyone would ever attempt to write actual programs in them. Any, anything other than fun. Like we don't think these are productive or efficient uses of your time in any way. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Like don't bring these up in an interview. Oh, well, so, so this white space one, I literally had a conversation today at work where, uh, at, at the job I work at, when we do interviews, we do them on whiteboards or chalkboards,
但主要是白板。我说我要吓唬下一个面试候选人，说我们要在白板上用 Whitespace 编码。你可以有一个像，有点像《搏击俱乐部》的时刻。就像在《搏击俱乐部》的结尾，那个人说，你知道，他意识到他是，好吧，你是剧透，不要剧透，呃，但，但，但，那可能会完全适得其反，因为你可以说你必须用 Whitespace 写它，而那个人可能会说，我已经写了所有可能的程序，或者像我已经做了，这是完美的答案，它在板上，那是个玩笑，但是的，是的，所以，所以 Whitespace，关于它的一个有趣的事情，关于它的另一个有趣的事情是，呃，呃，它忽略任何真实的字符，所以像，你知道，Java 和 C++ 这样的语言忽略空白，所以，呃，所以你实际上可以写一个 C++ 程序，里面嵌入了一个 Whitespace 程序，就像如果你编译它
but mostly whiteboards. And I said that I'm going to scare the next interview candidate by saying we're going to do coding in white space on the whiteboard. You could have a like, sort of like a Fight Club moment. Like at the end of Fight Club, the guy says, you know, he realizes he's well are you spoiler don't spoil um but but but uh that could totally backfire because you could say you have to write it in white space and the person could say i've just wrote every program possible or like i already did there's the perfect answer it's on the board that was a joke but yes yeah so yeah so so whitespace uh one kind of funny thing about it another funny thing about it is um um it it ignores any real characters and so languages like you know java and c++ ignore whitespace so um so you can actually write a c++ program that has a whitespace program embedded inside of it and like if you compiled it
用 Whitespace 编译器，你会得到一个工作的程序，如果你用 C++ 编译器编译它，你会得到另一个也工作的程序，但，呃，你知道，可能做了不同的事情，它们也可以做同样的事情，实际上如果它们有一个像 Whitespace 这样的东西，那会很酷，两个程序做相同的事情，是的，如果它们有一个 C++ 到 Whitespace 的转译器，但，但一个尊重事实的，像，有一些空格必须在那里，你知道，像复杂的，不在 Python 中做这个，哦，是的，Python 这个不会工作，但写一个程序，获取你的 C++ 程序并弄清楚并转译它到 Whitespace，然后把 Whitespace 放到程序中，那会很酷，但无论如何，那是疯狂的谈话，好吧，所以那是 Whitespace，我会回来下一个，我没有很多阿诺德·施瓦辛格的语录。
with the whitespace compiler you'd get one program that worked and if you compiled it with the c++ compiler you'd get a different program that also worked but uh you know potentially did something different they could also do the same actually that would be pretty cool if they have a white space like they do both programs do identical things yeah if they have a c++ to white space transpiler but but one that respected the fact that like there's some spaces that have to be there you know like complicated not doing this in python oh yeah python this wouldn't work but it'd be pretty cool to write a program which took your c++ program and figured out and transpiled it to white space and then put the white space in the program but anyways that's crazy talk um okay so that's white space uh i'll be back with the next one i don't't have very many Arnold Schwarzenegger quotes.
但下一个是 Arnold C。大多数关键字和函数调用都被阿诺德·施瓦辛格的电影台词所取代。我实际上不知道其中一些来自哪里。而且我可能不会再做任何模仿声音了。我需要读杰森推荐的表演书。是的，对。所以是表演时间，对
But the next one is Arnold C. And most of the keywords and function calls are replaced with Arnold Schwarzenegger movie quotes. I actually don't know where some of these are from. And I probably will not do any more impersonation voices. I need to read Jason's acting book that he recommended. Yeah, right. So it's showtime talk
手说你好世界，你已经被终止了，那不是阿诺德，那太糟糕了，好吧，你想试试杰森，嗯，我的意思是，没有你好世界，好吧，继续，那是什么，继续，是的，做它，在正确的，你好世界去，呃，是表演时间，哦，不，不，它像，呃，他怎么去，像对，手说，不，我和一些奥地利人一起工作，他是奥地利人，对吧，阿诺德·施瓦辛格，呃，我实际上和一个奥地利人一起工作，他听起来确实像阿诺德·施瓦辛格，这是，你告诉他了吗？因为我肯定没有人告诉过他，我肯定每个人，是的，每个人都告诉他，呃，是的，所以当 Arnold C 程序退出时，而不是仅仅，你知道，带括号的退出，它会说你已经被终止了，是的，所以，呃，这个只有在你用阿诺德·施瓦辛格的模仿说出所有这些时才很棒。
to the hand with hello world and you have been terminated that's not arnold that was terrible all right you want to try jason um yeah i mean so no hello world okay go ahead what's that go ahead yeah do it in the right the hello world goes uh it's showtime oh no no it's like uh how does he go like talk through the hand nope i work with some guy who's austrian he's austrian right arnold schwarzenegger um i actually work with a guy who's austrian and he does sound like arnold schwarzenegger which is do you tell him that because i'm sure no one's ever told him that i'm sure everyone yeah everyone tells him that um yeah and so when when the arnold c program exits instead of just you know exit with parentheses it goes you have been terminated yeah so um this one's only awesome if you say all of them in the Arnold Schwarzenegger impersonation.
是的，那是对的。所以很快，有这个想法的人是 Ryan。所以向你致敬，Ryan。他没有给我们姓氏或他来自哪里之类的。但向你致敬。这是一个很棒的节目想法，Ryan。谢谢。好的。
Yeah, that's right. So real quick, the guy who had the idea was Ryan. So props to you, Ryan. He didn't give us a last name or where he's from or anything. But props to you. This is a great idea for a show, Ryan. Thanks. Okay.
所以下一个涉及你更多的感官。那是对的，不仅仅是你的眼睛，你也应该涉及你的耳朵，听到你代码的音乐，那是对的，所以下一个是 Valito，velato，但它是一个，所以编译器的输入是一个 MIDI 文件，换句话说，你，你知道，你在键盘上弹奏一首歌，你把那首歌给 Valeto 编译器，出来的是一个计算机程序。所以它非常狂野。你实际上可以在构建它之前听到你的源代码。所以这个实际上很有趣，因为当我阅读关于它时，实际上你需要知道一些音乐理论才能理解它在说什么，所以例如，要，呃，有一个赋值，你知道，一个变量赋值
So next one is involving more of your senses. That's right of just your eyes you should also involve your ears and hear the music of your code that's right so the next one is Valito velato but it's a so the input to the compiler is a MIDI file so in other words you you know, you play a song on your keyboard, you give that song to the Valeto compiler and out comes a computer program. So it's pretty wild. You could actually hear your source code before you build it. So this one was actually interesting because when I was reading up about it, it's actually you need to know if some music theory to even understand what it's saying so for instance to uh to have an assignment you know an assignment a variable assignment
那么你必须把你的第二个音符弹奏为第一个音符上方的小三度，你不需要第三个音符，然后变量是一个单音符，然后，表达式。我甚至不知道那意味着什么。我不知道你刚才说了什么。If 语句是第三个音符是纯五度。好的。他们有，像，转译器吗？就像，我可以拿，你知道，像，工作中的一些代码，把它变成 Valeto，然后播放它吗？
then you have to play your second note as a minor third over the first note you don't need a third note and then the variable is a single note then then the expression. I don't even know what that means. I have no idea what you just said. An if statement is a third note being the perfect fifth. Okay. Do they have, like, transpiler? Like, can I take, you know, like, some code at work and turn it into Valeto and then play it?
我不知道。那会很酷。然后就像听听你现有的听起来像什么？是的，是的，是的。就像，哇，这是什么，你知道，这个库听起来像。而且它甚至有余地。所以命令音符，这是你的根音，而这些其他音程在这些之上，以，你知道，
I don't know. That would be cool. And then just like listen to what your existing one sounds like? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Be like, wow, this is what, you know, this library sounds like. And it even has allowances. So the command note, which is your root note, and these other intervals are on top of those to, you know,
说基本上 if 或无论什么，可以四处移动以允许更少重复，像实际上让它听起来有音乐感，哦，我明白了，呃，是的，所以这个很有趣，看程序本身就很美，因为它看起来就像疯狂的，像那个，我永远无法弹奏的音乐，因为它不仅仅是一次一个音符，而且，他们真的应该在维基百科上有一个东西，我的意思是，不是维基百科，维基百科有这个，但他们应该在这个特定的页面上有一个东西，你可以听到程序，呃，是的，是的，维基百科会发音某物，哦，实际上他们有它，它就在这里，好的，等
say basically if or whatever, can kind of move around to allow for less repetitive like actually make it sound musical oh i see uh yeah so this one's interesting it's just beautiful to look at the program because it just looks like crazy like that that music that i could never play because it's not just one note at a time and uh they really should have a thing in wikipedia i mean not wikipedia wikipedia has this but they should have a thing on this particular page where you could hear the program uh yeah yeah wikipedia will pronounce something oh actually they have it it's right here okay hang
一下，我要播放它，哎呀，等一下，我们要得到一个 DMCA 下架，这是你好世界，好的，它实际上有三分之二剩下的，但是的，那是，那是你好，好的，我什么也没听到，我本来想说它听起来很像我的程序，只是空的，好吧，你什么也没听到，不过没关系，好吧，呃，希望我们找到了它，或者这将是，好吧，我，我绝对播放了它，希望你的音频听众听到了它，好的，好的，酷，酷，也许，是的，也许我们稍后会检查它，不要担心编辑，你应该，你应该只是把它混音进去
on i'm gonna play it oops hang on we're gonna get a dnca takedown here's hello world okay it actually there's like two-thirds of it left but yeah that's that's hello okay i heard nothing i was gonna say it sounds a lot like my programs just empty well you didn't hear anything it's okay though well uh hopefully we found it or this will be well i i definitely played it hopefully the your audio audience heard it all right all right cool cool maybe yeah maybe we'll check it later don't worry about it in the editing you should just you should just mux it in
好的，是的，无论如何，它会被混音进去，是的，对话，是的，我本来想说维基百科页面有一个 mp3 的链接，如果你们想听的话，酷，好的，所以，呃，下一个是 Piet，你想谈谈 Piet，所以，呃，我们上一个是构建音乐程序，这个是，呃，使用你的绘画艺术家能力来构建程序。
okay yeah anyways it will have been muxed in yeah conversation yeah the I was gonna say the Wikipedia page has a link to the mp3 if you guys want to listen to it cool all right so um the next one is piet you want to talk about piet so uh our previous one was constructing musical programs this one is uh using your drawing artist ability to construct programs.
而且这实际上，所以 Piet，我相信，是，是蒙德里安的名字吗？蒙德里安 Piet 是创造那些像抽象方形画的人，像有红矩形和蓝矩形。也许我完全错了。你是对的。皮特·蒙德里安。哦，我说错了。我想我说蒙德里安和 Piet。无论如何，皮特·蒙德里安。
And this is actually, so Piet, I believe, is the name of, is it Mondrian? Mondrian Piet is the guy who created those kind of like abstract square paintings where like there's like a red rectangle and a blue rectangle. Maybe I'm completely. You're right. Piet Mondrian. Oh, I said it wrong. I think I said Mondrian and Piet. Anyways, Piet Mondrian.
其实，皮特，我相信，是那个名字，是蒙德里安吗？皮特·蒙德里安就是创作那些抽象方块画的人，画里有红色长方形和蓝色长方形。也许我完全记错了。你是对的。皮特·蒙德里安。哦，我说错了。我想我刚才说的是蒙德里安·皮特。总之，是皮特·蒙德里安。
So if you look at his pictures, there's like a classical, like I didn't know specifically, but I have seen his pictures before, like primary colored squares with like black outlines. It almost looked like a stained glass window in some ways. And he's kind of famous for those paintings. And so someone made
如果你看他的画，会有一种古典的感觉，我虽然说不出具体是什么，但我以前见过他的画，比如带有黑色轮廓的原色方块。在某种程度上，它看起来几乎就像彩色玻璃窗。他因这些画作而闻名。所以有人制作了
a programming language which uses that same similar style to actually be the program so it uses the colors and the pixel locations to create what the program is uh and of all the pages this one actually seems like the most filled out with like here's the compiler and here's like the documentation here's alternative ones and here's some gallery of uh you know collect ones this one seems pretty well put together yeah i love it and if you look at the if you go to the piet website and you look at the sample programs they have like hello world um they have one that prints like fibonacci numbers but then they have one it says towers of hanoi this program solves the towers of hanoi problem
一种编程语言，它使用类似的风格来编写程序，即利用颜色和像素位置来构建程序。在所有这些页面中，这一页看起来是最完善的，有编译器、文档、替代方案，还有一些收集到的作品集。这一页看起来制作得相当不错。是的，我喜欢它。如果你去Piet网站看他们的示例程序，他们有像“Hello World”这样的程序，有一个能打印斐波那契数列的程序，还有一个叫“汉诺塔”的程序，这个程序可以解决汉诺塔问题。
don't ask me how it works i have no idea that's what it says you know you have a good um funky programming language when nobody knows even the person who owns the language website doesn't know how how your program works yeah so again i i have no idea that you could be at all productive in this especially since like it appears that some of the colors are fairly close like different shades of red so a if you're colorblind i don't i i think you're just in trouble oh yeah and then even if you're just like there's like different shades of purple represent different things and maybe if you're like a designer and you're like really into various colors like this would work but so somebody wrote a piet um transpiler like a piet assembler they're
别问我它是怎么运作的，我完全不知道。这就是它所说的。你知道，当你拥有一门没人（甚至连语言网站的所有者）都不知道如何运作的编程语言时，你就知道这门语言有多么“时髦”了。是的，所以我还是不知道你怎么能在这种语言中提高效率，尤其是因为有些颜色看起来非常接近，比如不同深浅的红色。所以，如果你是色盲，我想你就有麻烦了。哦，是的，即使你不是色盲，比如不同深浅的紫色代表不同的含义，也许如果你是一位设计师，非常热衷于各种颜色，这可能会行得通。但有人写了一个Piet转译器，也就是一个Piet汇编器，他们
calling it okay and uh um and so they took a video game a text adventure game, and compiled it to Piet. And it is, as you would expect, just like a gigantic. So if you're watching the stream, you can actually see what I'm seeing, which is just a gigantic image. And supposedly, if you compile this image with theX compiler, you'd get a text adventure game. Ooh. Fun. Pretty cool, yeah. But did you ever use, what was that?
称之为“Okay”。他们拿了一个文字冒险游戏，并将其编译为Piet。正如你所料，它看起来就像一个巨大的图像。如果你正在看直播，你可以看到我所看到的，那只是一个巨大的图像。据称，如果你用X编译器编译这个图像，你就能得到一个文字冒险游戏。噢，真有趣。很酷，对吧。但你有没有用过那个，叫什么来着？
Why is the name escaping me now? The one with the little turtles and you can move the turtles. Oh, yeah, Logo. Logo, yes. It's kind of like I feel like these programs should be animated, like actually do stuff when they run, like produce pictures as the output as well yeah like if like it seems anticlimactic that you draw this beautiful program of music or whatever and then the output is like an actual
为什么我记不起那个名字了？就是那个有小乌龟，你可以移动乌龟的程序。哦，是的，Logo。Logo，没错。我觉得这些程序应该是动画形式的，比如在运行时真正做点什么，或者输出一些图片作为结果。是的，如果你画出了一个精美的音乐程序或其他什么东西，但输出结果却是一个实际的
executable that just runs and does normal stuff yeah yeah totally there should be like a memory visualizer or something oh there you go yeah yeah yeah i wonder if that you should get on that jason all your free time yeah i'll get right on my free time yeah oh man um cool all right yeah that's so there's a ton of these funky languages many more um yeah yeah definitely check them out we covered some you know most of the major ones the major ones i see you did it that was a music reference yeah oh man um so uh uh yeah we covered most of them but uh there's there's plenty more and uh you especially the ones that have you know the assemblers or transpilers where you can take you know your college project and turn it into um valeto or piet without any um you know work on your part that would be pretty hilarious to to submit that you know what i mean it's like i know no yeah well
可执行文件，只是运行并做一些普通的事情，这感觉有点虎头蛇尾。是的，确实应该有一个内存可视化工具之类的东西。哦，你说得对。我想你应该去搞定它，杰森，利用你所有的空闲时间。是的，我会利用我的空闲时间去做的。哦，天哪。酷，好吧，确实有很多这种时髦的语言，还有更多。是的，一定要去看看。我们已经涵盖了一些主要的语言。我看到你刚才做了个音乐梗，哦，天哪。所以，我们涵盖了大部分，但还有很多。特别是那些有汇编器或转译器的语言，你可以把你大学的项目变成Valeto或Piet，而不需要你做任何工作。如果能提交那个作品，那会非常搞笑，你懂我的意思吗？我知道，不，好吧。
i don't want to get anyone in trouble but like if you if you could somehow submit a piet drawing instead of your homework but then maybe like also submit your homework then uh programming interviews do not do programming interviews in velado and like drawing notes on the boards and bass clefs and no don't do that yeah could you imagine if someone said, yeah, I only write in Piat. I'm going to need a marker of each type, of each color. Oh, no. No. Okay. This is devolving quickly.
我不想让任何人惹上麻烦，但如果你能以某种方式提交一幅Piet画作来代替你的家庭作业，但也许同时也提交你的作业……那么，编程面试时千万不要用Velado，也不要在白板上画音符和低音谱号，千万别那样做。你能想象如果有人说：“是的，我只用Piet编写代码。我需要每种颜色、每种类型的记号笔。”哦，不，不。好吧，这话题跑偏得太快了。
All right. Well, if we missed your favorite funky language, you can write us and let us know. Maybe we'll have to do funky languages part two. Yeah. Yeah, this is a lot of fun um thank you guys for your continued comments of uh that we're doing good that you don't like something that uh you have questions for us it's all really good recently i i was browsing uh the tech category of podcasts in itunes and noticed that of all tech podcasts so that includes things like leo reports like this week in tech uh you
好吧，如果我们错过了你最喜欢的时髦语言，你可以写信告诉我们。也许我们得做一期“时髦语言第二部分”。是的，这真的很有趣。感谢你们持续的评论，告诉我们做得不错，或者你们不喜欢什么，以及你们向我们提出的问题，这些都非常好。最近我在iTunes上浏览播客的技术分类时注意到，在所有的技术播客中，包括像Leo的报道、《本周技术》这样的节目，我们
know some really big major brand uh podcasts we were number 74 so that was pretty good i have no idea what arbitrary rating they're using but uh we were number 74 so i was happy to see our little icon in the list with all these other like i know what that podcast is. And Hey, like those people are big. Yeah. Yeah. So, I mean, thanks a lot guys for your, for your support.
排在第74位，这相当不错。我不知道他们使用的是什么任意的评分标准，但我们排在第74位，所以我很高兴在列表中看到我们的小图标，旁边还有其他我知道的播客。嘿，那些人可是大咖。是的，所以，非常感谢你们的支持。
I mean, you're the reason why, uh, why, uh, you know, we get, uh,
我的意思是，你们就是我们获得
we get the downloads and the, and the ratings, things like that. So we definitely appreciate it. Um, you know, we're, we're doing,
下载量和评分的原因。所以我们绝对非常感激。我们
we're going to do this Twitch stream for at least a couple more shows. So, uh, feel free to jump on. It looks like we're up to like three people. yeah so that's current viewers but how many like over the course have viewed our stream oh i haven't been looking uh but uh i was gonna i was gonna make fun of us and then i briefly went to twitch and noticed the one on their main like their home page that they were featuring was people sitting around a table playing uh pen and paper dungeons and
打算至少再做几期Twitch直播。所以，欢迎随时加入。看起来我们现在有三个人了。是的，那是当前的观众，但总共有多少人看过我们的直播呢？哦，我没注意。但我本来想调侃一下我们，然后我简短地看了一下Twitch，注意到他们主页上推荐的是人们围坐在桌子旁玩纸笔版《龙与地下城》
dragons so i'm not sure that we're that far off from that so maybe this isn't such a bad idea no offense to dungeons and dragons or wonderful people playing it i'm sure it was i've played pen and paper before it's been fun but uh um yeah so so uh you know thanks a lot for your support it's been awesome um you know uh next time I'll give people more notice. And you can jump on and talk to some of the other people who are fans of the show. What else? Hopefully we answered.
所以我不确定我们离那种状态有多远，所以也许这并不是一个坏主意。对《龙与地下城》或玩它的精彩玩家没有冒犯之意，我相信它很有趣。我以前玩过纸笔游戏，很有意思。但总之，非常感谢你们的支持，这太棒了。下次我会提前通知大家。你们可以加入并与其他粉丝交流。还有什么？希望我们回答了。
Oh, one other thing is, you know, last episode i talked about rejection sampling um so i briefly talked about this idea of like distributions and sampling easy distributions you know to get more difficult distributions and anyways um you know so so check back on the last episode if you want to recap of that but somebody was sort of inspired from that and then kind of did some research on Wikipedia and stuff like that. And actually implemented rejection sampling. And let me actually put it in the show notes. So check this link out. This guy actually implemented it in IPython notebook.
哦，还有一件事，上一集我谈到了拒绝采样。我简要谈到了分布和采样简单分布以获得更复杂分布的想法。总之，如果你想回顾一下，可以看看上一集。有人从中得到了启发，然后在维基百科上做了一些研究，并实际实现了拒绝采样。让我把它放在节目说明里。看看这个链接。这家伙实际上是在IPython Notebook中实现的。
And so you can actually run it in the browser and uh um and see the result and stuff like that even as like visual talk about viewer feedback yeah it's pretty freaking awesome so uh so props to you for for doing that um and uh yeah and it actually made me check out ipython notebook like give it another look and actually i think it's pretty awesome um definitely a big fan so i don't think i said this last time but um i have a little bit of a confession to make so i think okay when uh when i was in what is this probably like uh fifth grade sixth grade science fair i actually essentially did this for my science fair project oh really you made like a notebook kind of thing no no so i made a random number generator out of
所以你可以在浏览器中运行它，并查看结果，甚至可以进行可视化。谈谈观众反馈，这真是太棒了。所以，为你这样做点个赞。这实际上让我去查看了IPython Notebook，重新审视了一下，我觉得它非常棒，绝对是它的忠实粉丝。我不认为我上次说过这个，但我有一个小小的忏悔。我想，当我在五年级或六年级参加科学博览会时，我实际上基本上为我的科学博览会项目做了这个。哦，真的吗？你做了一个笔记本之类的东西？不，不。我用
like electrical components that i'd found you know like some uh like in radio shack or whatever and you would push the button and it would give you a random number and then i collected a whole bunch of random numbers then like uh used i think it was like mathematic at the time to like plot them all you know with like a quarter quadrant of a circle and like determine how many were in or out of the circle and basically calculated pi using my random number generator as my science fair project wow did you win that sounds like an amazing project so no oh yeah my science fair project was was terrible it actually you're gonna laugh my science fair project literally was a solar powered flashlight
我在Radio Shack或其他地方找到的电子元件制作了一个随机数生成器。你按下按钮，它就会给出一个随机数。然后我收集了一大堆随机数，然后用当时的Mathematica软件把它们全部绘制出来，比如在一个圆的四分之一象限内，确定有多少点在圆内或圆外，基本上是用我的随机数生成器计算出了圆周率，作为我的科学博览会项目。哇，你赢了吗？听起来是个了不起的项目。没有，哦，是的，我的科学博览会项目太糟糕了。实际上，你会笑的，我的科学博览会项目字面上就是一个太阳能手电筒。
literally like i i felt like if you were like trying to look into an area but the flashlight could still have i didn't get it i didn't get it at first i was like why are you being so down on yourself that sounds fine and then i'm like oh wait like it only worked for like a minute because like the capacitor was tiny right it just is terrible but uh so sebastian uh rashka i'm sorry if i butchered your name but sebastian's the one who um actually wrote this ipython notebook and uh it's very and i wasn't putting it down by saying i did that like as a science fair project a long time ago i was just admitting how nerdy i mean if i was the judge you would have won first place no but i
字面上就是这样。我觉得如果你试图往一个区域里看，但手电筒……我没明白，我一开始没明白。我当时想，你为什么要这么贬低自己？这听起来不错。然后我意识到，哦，等等，它只能工作一分钟，因为电容器太小了，对吧？这简直太糟糕了。但总之，Sebastian Raschka，如果我读错了你的名字我很抱歉，但Sebastian是那个真正写了这个IPython Notebook的人。我并不是说我以前做那个科学博览会项目是在贬低它，我只是承认我有多书呆子气。如果我是评委，你会赢得第一名。不，但我
think the judges didn't get it so i think like someone who did like do trees do better with rock music or not one oh yeah yeah so you were like a savant like no no it wasn't that at all it was just very like it's out there right people like i don't get it like yeah yeah anyways it was more math than science i blame myself yeah you ended up like two positions below the rock music but you did better than the guy who made facebook for the science fair project the judges are just that out of touch no oh no okay all right they were like y combinator judges okay wrapping this up till next time all right yeah we're getting in trouble so uh thanks a lot for the support you guys uh community is awesome we love the feedback the emails the questions uh people who take what we say and actually implement it. Totally props
认为评委们没看懂。所以我想，像那些做“树木在摇滚乐下是否长得更好”之类项目的人赢了。哦，是的，所以你就像个天才。不，根本不是那样，它只是非常……它太超前了，对吧？人们会说“我不明白”。总之，它更像是数学而不是科学，我怪我自己。是的，你最终的排名比摇滚乐项目低了两个位置，但你比那个在科学博览会上做Facebook的人做得好。评委们就是那么脱节。哦，不，好吧。好吧，结束这一期，直到下次。好的，我们惹麻烦了。所以，非常感谢你们的支持，社区太棒了。我们喜欢反馈、电子邮件、问题，以及那些采纳我们建议并付诸实践的人。完全要给你们点赞。
to you guys. The next time we go on Twitch, we'll give you a couple days or a week notice so we can get more community. There's some people chatting in there, but hopefully we'll get more people on there and you can give us some
下次我们去Twitch直播时，我们会提前几天或一周通知，这样我们就能吸引更多的社区成员。现在有一些人在聊天，但希望我们能吸引更多人，这样你们就能给我们提供一些
instantaneous feedback if we mess up or something like that. Alright. Sounds good. more people on there and you can give us some instantaneous feedback if we mess up or something like that all right cool sounds good all right have a good one guys see you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即时反馈，如果我们搞砸了或者类似的事情。好的，听起来不错。更多的人加入，你们就能给我们提供一些即时反馈，如果我们搞砸了或者类似的事情。好的，酷，听起来不错。好的，祝大家过得愉快，回头见。片头音乐是Biner Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播该作品，进行改编，但必须注明Patrick和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。